aquí tenemos la gráfica fx y queremos
encontrar cuánto vale el límite de fx
cuando x tiende a menos 3 y si solo
vemos en x igual a menos 3 puedes ver
que es muy difícil ver solo basándonos
en esta gráfica cuánto es
efe de menos 3 y además se ve como si
tuviéramos una discontinuidad asintótica
en x igual a menos 3 parece que en el
lado izquierdo cuando nos aproximamos a
menos 3 nos vamos a bueno nos vamos a
infinito y también parece que en el lado
derecho cuando nos aproximamos a x igual
a menos 3 nos vamos también a infinito
así que viendo esto podemos preguntarnos
cuánto es
efe 5 bueno está aquí es 4 cuánto es
efe de menos 4 es aproximadamente 8 lo
podemos ver por aquí cuantos efe - 3
bueno eso es justo lo que buscamos pero
podemos ver que al acercarnos a esta
discontinuidad asintótica que tenemos
por aquí nos vamos acercando
a infinito tomamos valores cada vez más
grandes
si nos aproximamos a menos tres por el
lado izquierdo nos vamos acercando más y
más y más a infinito ahora pensemos qué
es lo que pasa cuando nos acercamos a
menos tres por la derecha así que este
es efe de menos uno
este es efe - 2 este es efe de menos 2.5
parece que toma un valor por aquí y ft
menos 2.9 tomará un valor más grande y
efe de menos 2.99 tomará uno más grande
aún y otra vez parece que nos
aproximamos a infinito así que este tipo
de límite en algún contexto puedes decir
simplemente que este límite no existe
este límite no existe no existe de una
manera formal así que esta es una forma
de pensarlo y en otro contexto escuchar
a esa persona es decir que por la
izquierda y por la derecha parece que
tiende a infinito
así que algunas veces escucharás decir
que este límite tiende a infinito y
bueno esto depende del contexto en el
que estés pero en una forma tradicional
para hablar de límites en una forma
técnica ya que hay formas de definir
límites donde esto tiene un poco más de
sentido en la forma tradicional diremos
que este límite no existe aunque pensar
que tiende a infinito sea un poco más
intuitivo